RADICAL MEMBERS OF THE SQUAD
SLAMMING ISRAEL MOMENTS AGO.
THIS COMES AS TOP DEMOCRATS
REPORTEDLY THREATENED TO
RETALIATE AFTER RASHIDA TLAIB
AND ILHAN OMAR WERE BANNED FROM
ENTERING THE COUNTRY.
THE WHITE HOUSE FIRING BACK
AGAINST HOUSE DEMOCRATS PLANS TO
PUNISH THE U.S. AND ISRAELI
AMBASSADORS WITH LEGISLATIVE
ACTION.
TLAIB AND OMAR WERE DENIED
ACCESS TO ISRAEL OVER SUPPORT OF
A BOYCOTT MOVEMENT AND ISRAEL
GRANTED TLAIB ACCESS ON
HUMANITARIAN GROUNDS AND SHE
TURNED HER DOWN.
OMAR ALSO TAKING A SWIPE AT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> WE KNOW DONALD TRUMP WOULD
LOVE NOTHING MORE THAN TO USE
THIS ISSUE TO PIT MUSLIMS AND
JEWISH AMERICANS AGAINST EACH
OTHER.
THE MUSLIM COMMUNITY AND THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY ARE BEING
OTHERRED AND MADE IN TO THE
BOGEYMAN BY THIS ADMINISTRATION.
>> Jesse: OMAR ALSO UNDER FIRE
FOR SHARING A CONTROVERSIAL
CARTOON ON SOCIAL MEDIA BY AN
ANTI-SEMITIC ARTIST.
THIS IS PRESIDENT TRUMP LASTING
THE PAIR, SAYING THEY HAVE SUCH
DISDAIN FOR ISRAEL.
DANA, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AGAIN
ON ITS HEELS OVER ANTI-SEMITISM
AND AGAIN LOOKS LIKE THE FACE OF
THE PARTY AS THE SQUAD, IS THIS
WHAT NANCY PELOSI WANTS?
>> Dana: I PROBABLY SHOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN SURPRISED THEY HAD A
PRESS CONFERENCE TODAY BUT I'M
SLIGHTLY SURPRISED BECAUSE I
THINK THEY COULD'VE TURNED THE
PAGE, GET IT BEHIND THEM, MOVE
ON TO DO SOMETHING ELSE BUT BY
HAVING A PRESS CONFERENCE TODAY
AND TRYING TO SHOWCASE THAT THEY
JUST ENSURED THE WHITE HOUSE IS
PROBABLY GOING TO RESPOND AGAIN
IN EVERY DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE IS
GOING UP TO ANSWER IT AND THE
PRESIDENT'S GOING SAY SOMETHING
AND THEN WE COULD GO ANOTHER
WEEK TALKING ABOUT THIS AND I --
MY GUT INSTINCT IS THAT THEY ARE
NOT WINNING THIS ARGUMENT.
THEY MIGHT THINK THEY ARE
WINNING THE ARGUMENT.
IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE IT.
>> Jesse: WHAT DOES IT SAY
THAT THEY DO THINK THEY ARE
WINNING THE ARGUMENT?
>> Greg: I THINK THEY HAVE
LEARNED IN THIS TRUMP ERA THAT
CONFLICT CREATES THE NEWS.
WE CARRIED THIS PRESS
CONFERENCE.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE PROBABLY
CARRIED A PRESS CONFERENCE LIKE
THAT A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
I DON'T THINK WE WOULD, WOULD W
WE?
MINOR POLITICIANS IN MINNESOTA,
IT BECOMES A NATIONAL NEWS AND
THEY LOVE IT.
IT'S GREAT FOR THEIR BRAND.
I THINK THE LEFT IS IN EFFECT
BECAUSE HOW MANY PEOPLE WHO
NEVER KNEW WHAT THE BDS MOVEMENT
WAS NOW KNOW ABOUT IT.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A MEDICAL
DISORDER THAT'S ADVERTISED ON
CABLE.
BUT IT'S LIKE NOW I WATCHED
MEDIA WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT THE
BDS MOVEMENT.
THEY HAVE TO LOOK DOWN AND THEY
GO THE BDS MOVEMENT STANDS FOR
UH, WHAT DOES IT STAND FOR?
BOYCOTT INVESTMENT, SANCTION.
IN THE TRUMP ERA, WE ARE
LEARNING ABOUT STUFF THAT WE
PROBABLY DIDN'T LEARN ABOUT
BEFORE AND I DON'T THINK IT
HELPS THEM BECAUSE ONCE PEOPLE
LEARN ABOUT THE BDS MOVEMENT,
THEY SEE THAT ITS ORIGINS ARE
ANTI-SEMITIC, MUCH LIKE THE
CARTOON.
THE CARTOON WASN'T VERY GOOD BUT
THE GUY WAS A CONTESTANT AND A
HOLOCAUST DENIAL CONTEST.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD BOOK FOR THE
SQUAD.
CAN I GO BACK TO THE POINT ABOUT
THE NEW RULES OF ENGAGEMENT?
BEFORE TRUMP, THIS WAS A ONE-WAY
STREET.
THE FAR LEFT ANTI-SEMITIC
SANCTIONS COULD WAGE WAR ON
ISRAEL AND YOU HAVE TO GRIN AND
BEAR IT.
NOW THERE'S PUSHBACK AND WHEN
YOU PUSH BACK THE ACCUSE YOU OF
BEING THE BULLY.
>> Jesse: IT'S NOT
CONSERVATIVES.
BILL MAHER, PRETTY LIBERAL, HE
CAME OUT TO THE BDS MOVEMENT WAS
GARBAGE AND TOOK A PRETTY HARD
POSITION AGAINST THE SQUAD AND
THEN RASHIDA TLAIB CAME BACK AND
SAID MAYBE WE SHOULD BOYCOTT
DELMAR.
>> Juan: LET ME SEE THEY ARE
WINNING THIS ARGUMENT.
I THINK SO.
>> Jesse: WHAT EVIDENCE IS
THERE?
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY QUESTION THAT THERE'S BEEN A
BACKLASH.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS,
JEWISH PEOPLE, MUSLIMS, THEY ARE
ALL SAYING THAT ISRAEL SHOULD'VE
LET THEM IN AND DON'T FORGET,
NETANYAHU SAID HE WANTED TO LET
THEM IN UNTIL PRESIDENT TRUMP
TWEETED AT HIM.
>> Jesse: PELOSI HAPPY WITH
THIS?
>> Juan: I THINK VERY HAPPY.
TO DOUBLE DOWN ON GREG'S POINT,
IT MAKES MORE PEOPLE AWARE OF
THE BOYCOTT DIVESTMENT AND
SANCTIONS MOVEMENT THAN EVER
BEFORE.
>> Jesse: AND THAT'S A GOOD
THING?
>> Juan: I DISAGREE WITH IT
BUT I MUST SAY SUDDENLY
EVERYBODY'S TALKING ABOUT IT.
I THINK THIS IS KILLING THE D.C.
CONSENSUS OF SUPPORT FOR ISRAEL.
I THINK IT'S BECOMING
POLITICALLY POLARIZED, LIKE SO
MUCH.
I REMEMBER WHEN PEOPLE WERE
UPSET THAT BENJAMIN NETANYAHU
WAS INVITED BY THE REPUBLICANS
TO COME TO CONGRESS AND
CRITICIZED PRESIDENT OBAMA.
BUT IT WENT BY.
NOW THIS HAS BEEN DOUBLED DOWN
BY TRUMP SO THAT NOW EVERYTHING
IS SO POLITICAL ABOUT ISRAEL AND
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS FOR
THE LONGEST TIME, LOOK AT OUR
FINANCIAL SUPPORT, MILITARY
SUPPORT, PRO-ISRAEL.
AND NOW NETANYAHU AT TRUMP'S
BEHEST IS DIVIDING IT.
>> Greg: CALLING IT AN
OCCUPATION IS KIND OF --
>> Jesse: TO THE ISRAELI
PRIME MINISTER IS THE ONE BEING
DIVISIVE, NOT THE SQUAD?
>> Katie: I AGREE WITH JUAN ON
ONE THING.
IT DOES PUSH THE DEMOCRATIC
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FURTHER AWAY
FROM ISRAEL BECAUSE DEMOCRATS
ARE TAKING THE SIDE OF
RASHIDA TLAIB AND ILHAN OMAR
INSTEAD OF A LONG-STANDING ALLY
AND YOU COULD SAY THEY ARE
AMERICANS, THEY ARE
CONGRESSWOMEN THAT'S WHY WERE
DOING IT BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
RECORD AND WHY THEY WERE NOT
ALLOWED IN THE COUNTRY, THE
GROUP THEY ARE GOING WITH
CELEBRATE SUICIDE BOMBERS WHO
NOT ONLY KILL ISRAELIS BUT ALSO
AMERICANS.
THEY GLORIFIED TERRORISTS WHO
KILLED CHILDREN.
THAT'S ONE REASON THEY ARE LEFT
OUT.
DURING A PRESS CONFERENCE AND
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE GOING FOR,
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT SO MUCH
MISINFORMATION.
THEY ARE ACTING LIKE IT'S ABOUT
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU WHEN IT'S
ABOUT BDS WHICH IS A MOVEMENT
THAT'S BEEN AROUND FOR FAR
LONGER THAN ONE POLITICAL PARTY
EITHER IN THE U.S. OR IN ISRAEL.
IT'S ABOUT NOT ALLOWING THE
COUNTRY TO EXIST.
RASHIDA TLAIB TALKS ABOUT THE
WALLS AND ISRAEL NOT BEING
EFFECTIVE.
ACTUALLY, THEY ARE, KEEPING
SUICIDE BOMBERS OUT OF ISRAEL
AND SO THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT THEY'RE PUTTING ON THE
TABLE THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT TERMS OF HUMAN RIGHTS THAT
DON'T DRIVE WITH THE LEFTIST
NARRATIVE.
JUST TODAY THE PALESTINIAN
AUTHORITY BANNED ALL LGBTQ
ACTIVITY IN THE WEST BANK WHILE
ISRAEL HAS ONE OF THE LARGEST
GAY RIGHTS PARADES IN THE WORLD.
THEY'RE GOING TO FIGURE OUT,
DEMOCRATS, WHETHER THEY SUPPORT
REAL HUMAN RIGHTS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST WHICH COME WITH
ISRAEL, INCLUDING FOR ARAB
ISRAELIS, OR WHETHER THEY
SUPPORT TWO CONGRESSWOMEN WHO
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH GROUP TO
CELEBRATE SUICIDE BOMBINGS.
AGAINST AMERICAN CITIZENS.
>> Jesse: WAS IN THIS EXPOSED
AS A STUNT WHEN THE ISRAELI
GOVERNMENT LET TLAIB COME IN AND
SHE SAID NO.
>> Greg: USING THE GRANDMOTHER
AS A PROP.
SHE WROTE IN A LETTER THIS MAY
BE THE LAST TIME I SEE MY
GRANDMOTHER AND THEN SHE DECIDES
NOT TO SEE HER GRANDMOTHER.
BUT SHE FINDS TIME TO POST THIS
OTHER CARTOON.
I'M GOING TO SAY I DON'T TRUST
HER.
I DON'T TRUST ANYBODY THAT WOULD
USE THEIR IN SUCH A MANNER.
SHE SHOULD APOLOGIZE TO HER
GRANDMOTHER.
DANA.
RIGHT?
>> Dana: THE TWO OF THEM
COULD'VE GONE ON THE TRIP THE
WEEK BEFORE WITH 51 MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
30 REPUBLICANS, 21 DEMOCRATS.
THEY COULD'VE ALL GONE TOGETHER.
FROM WHAT I HEARD FROM THAT
TRIP, ALL VIEWS WERE EXPRESSED
IN THESE VIEWS COULD HAVE BEEN.
>> Juan: KEVIN McCARTHY,
LEADER OF THE REPUBLICANS IN THE
HOUSE SAID YEAH, THEY SHOULD'VE
BEEN LEADING.
EVERYBODY SHOULD GO.
>> Dana: I AM SAYING THEY
SHOULD'VE GONE WITH THE WHOLE
GROUP.
>> Juan: I DON'T PICK THEY
HAVE TO GO BY ANYBODY'S --
>> Greg: AREN'T WE PAYING FOR
IT?
IT WOULD BE CHEAPER AS A GROUP.
>> Dana: THIS GROUP.
>> Katie: THEY SHOULD GO WITH
THE GROUP --
>> Juan: ALWAYS BEEN ALLOWED
TO GO.
OUR PRESIDENT TELLING OF THE
NATION'S PRESIDENT.
DON'T LET MY POLITICAL OPPONENTS
IN.
NOW THIS EFFORT TO SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT THE AMBASSADORS, THEY ARE
JUST PROXIES FOR NETANYAHU AND
TRUMP.
>> Katie: CAN I SAY ONE MORE
THING ABOUT THE AID POINT THAT
ILHAN OMAR AND RASHIDA TLAIB ARE
SAYING WE GIVE ISRAEL $3 BILLION
IN AID.
AID TO ISRAEL IS AN INVESTMENT
BECAUSE IN RETURN THEY GIVE OF
TECHNOLOGY, COUNTERTERRORISM
OPERATIONS, THE PALESTINIANS USE
OUR TAXPAYER MONEY TO PAY
TERRORISTS AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
TERRORISTS AND THEIR FAMILIES TK
TERRORISTS AND THEIR FAMILIES TL
AMERICANS AND ISRAELIS.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
ONCE THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT
WHEN IT COMES TO ISRAEL?
WE GET A LOT IN RETURN FOR THE
AID WE'RE GIVING THEM.
>> Jesse: MAYBE THEY DIDN'T GO
TO ISRAEL WITH THE OTHER
DELEGATION.
RUBY THEY HAD IN THE PARMA THEY
COULDN'T CHANGE.
THERE SOMETIMES CONFLICT.
>> Juan: CRITICIZED AN
AMERICAN PRESIDENT IN OUR
COUNTRY.